we've got the CEO of Technology
Foundation Berlin with us Nicholas
Zimmer you're coordinating the next
Industrial Revolution so to speak for
the German startups Association is it a
and I hope they're not watching right
now but is it a challenging job or just
frustrating well it tends to be both
that's right so on one hand it's very
interesting to see what startups come up
with as ideas but when you see how hard
it is to get that implemented in the
real world legacy industry it's it's
sometimes it's it's mind-bending how
much people don't understand that this
is a very urgent thing they have to
tackle I think most of the companies and
companies company leaders have
understood that it's something which is
important but what they don't see is
that it's urgent
because they see their order books
they're full so they say everything is
fine and I think that this is one of the
major problems we have it isn't just the
case of hiring a few natives digital
natives I mean they they use snapchat
they know how the digital world works
and social media to get them on board
would fix their problems wouldn't it
unfortunately it's not working this way
oh one hand I mean that that's one of
the great misperceptions they see young
people using snapchat or Facebook or
whatever and they think well there are
digital natives they know how a digital
economy works that's not the case
they're just using something they play
with so I want don't want to be too
offensive but it's basically the
question of whether people can think
digitally and that's not the case was
most of the people that are leaving our
schools and universities second problem
is a cultural problem if you bring
startup people into legacy companies
every start of thinking will die within
hours or at least days because the
culture of German companies is very
incremental they are innovating
incremental and they're looking into
their one product they usually have and
they want to make it better day by day
and they're looking into what the
customers demand from them the startup
works differently a start-up looks into
somebody has an idea and somebody wants
to revolutionize something and somebody
wants to shoot for the moon yeah and so
they are they're doing everything which
is necessary for this and they are
tackling problems from different sides
so they will come up with
it's not working to the next idea that's
a pivoting we're always talking about
the startups so they have a very
different mindset about how to come to a
product which is working on the market
okay well let's get to that read back to
that revolution in a moment back to you
in a moment
Nicholas first of all let's look more
about more into the industrial side of
things so Nicholas it all sounds very
smart but just how many companies are
actually following the lead of these
select few em am i right in saying that
it's just a select few that are managing
to get ahead in the digital world
definitely I would say five to ten
percent are really on in the top tire
and then there will be like 10 to 15%
who try to keep up and I think the broad
feel is basically still waiting what
comes we did a survey in Berlin and this
is basically the same numbers we got
well it doesn't it also make it hard
that the internet speed in Germany isn't
the fastest you'd think that Germany
would be right up there in the ranks but
if we have a look at the numbers
internationally South Korea has the
fastest web it's followed by Hong Kong
Norway Sweden and Switzerland and then
Germany's all the way down in 26th place
why is that yeah that's a good question
I mean that would be you some investment
which would make sense basically but on
the other hand the Deutsche Telekom
usually says if nobody pays us to bring
less fibre to somewhere then we will not
do it so I think this is one of the
biggest issues we have to tackle bring
connectivity to the company so they can
really work on real time basis digitally
because you can't work on a real-time
basis if you don't have broadband how
else can Germany draw on its strengths
it's got this strong backbone of SMEs
some amazing firms in niche markets what
can I do to get ahead or keep up at
least in the digital race well I think
on one hand yes we have world leaders
and they have a distribution network and
they have an image which is very
important even in those digitized times
so they can do on that and I think that
we have to return to the idea of being
Tigres of solving problems of technical
problems from different sides
not too much concentrating on that
incremental process we learned over the
last 100 years but going back to the
elephant's Aman's or whatever you want
to take great advice
I hope we see some change technology
foundation Berlin CEO Nicolas simmer
thank you very much for coming thank you